- I took a little diversion
on the way back from
filming last week's video.
It is very cold and
windy at this altitude.
But, tucked away in the Swiss Alps,
there's a military airfield with not one
but two public roads that go
straight across the runway
and I have wanted to see
this for a long time.
This is Meiringen air base.
And not only do the fighter jets here
have to cope with civilian
traffic crossing their runway
but the spectacle of military aircraft
roaring down the tarmac
attracts tourists
from all over the world.
So I wanted to ask: how
do they operate an airbase
where the public aren't
just turning up to watch
but they can also walk, ride,
or drive straight through?
- I don't know how many times
I took off,
how many times I've landed.
Well, let's say around a hundred takeoffs,
which equals a hundred landings.
But every single one is very cool.
At times, there can be
a lot of tourists and observers
all around the airfield,
especially in summer.
They stay behind the barriers.
They're outside of the fence.
But it's all threat-level dependent.
So at the moment we're at peace,
there's no problem.
If we were to find ourselves
in a crisis...
it would be
another story.
- Okay.
All right. Where am I
allowed to stand?
- Alright, look down. Right here.
You're going to be all safe.
- Yep.
- The jets are going
to come from that side.
Going to take off here.
Back here, you're safe.
- [exhales, laughs]
I mean you fly them, so...!
- I do!
[crossing warning beeps]
When we're ready for takeoff
the air traffic controllers
close the barriers.
They themselves have a look if
they see anything suspicious.
And then whenever the
barriers get closed,
there's guys from the military police
on both sides of the barriers.
Also, there's the runway controller
who observes every takeoff
and every landing.
He could step in as well.
So we as pilots, we can't
do much ourselves.
- There are a few other
runways in the world
with roads across them,
but they're all
very small and very remote.
In Sumburgh, on the island of Shetland,
in the far north of the UK
there is a commercial airport
with a similar setup
across one of its two runways,.
But that is very remote.
It used to be that the only road
in and out of Gibraltar
went right across a
massive airport runway.
One that took full size passenger jets.
But there is finally
a new tunnel there now
after years of delays.
So cars and trucks no longer go that way.
So this runway here in
Switzerland would be just
a little side note, if it wasn't
for the tourist industry
that sprung up around it.
If you're the sort of
aviation or military nerd
that wants to see fighter jets
up close and personal
this is probably on your
list of places to visit.
And if you didn't know
about it before this video,
it probably is now.
There's a very nice
restaurant just off the base.
One of the hangers is open
to the public occasionally
and there's a massive military
air show every October.
This place is good PR
for the Swiss Air Force.
- If ever there should be
anyone between the barriers
when we are coming back to land,
we would be ordered
to go-around.
So we would abort our approach,
climb again and
do a second approach whenever
the issue has been resolved.
When we take off, it's basically
the other way around.
We taxi it towards the runway
and once we report ready
to the air traffic controller,
they close the barriers
and they give us our
clearance to to take off
once everything is settled
- It's not like there are
any statistics to compare
but that crossing is probably more safe
than most railroad crossings.
Although to be fair, the rail industry
is trying to get rid
as many of those as they can,
because they are an
unnecessary safety risk.
[loud jet engine, increasing]
[jet engine roaring]
I cannot explain how loud that was.
I've got full ear-defender earplugs in.
I think it might have
broken my microphone.
Wow. We had one take to get that.
I hope I didn't fluff my lines. [laughing]